well Calif you started in California
that's where the brand comes from and
we're actually named after the origin of
California so Queen Cal fiha was a
mythical figure that became the namesake
of the state so we're surrounded by
almond groves and orange groves and so
on and so the source of the material
that we make was your plant milks all
comes from there and the UK is a very
progressive beverage market and it's it
seems like it really the population here
really wants to have a broader selection
of these plant-based milk alternatives
do you think then that the dairy
alternative markets do have some ways to
grow here in Britain oh absolutely I
think what we're seeing is just the
beginning and Califf er brand focuses on
trying to approach it more from a
category expansion point of view and
flavors shapes packaging usage occasions
mixing it with coffee things like matcha
and you know cold brew coffee all create
a different level of interest on the
part of the consumer and I think help
wake people up too there's a whole world
of these kind of beverages which are low
in sugar and offer a real alternative to
dairy and juice products but are the
health benefits of alternatives to lines
like dairy over stated times I mean for
example as a story on the front page of
the newspapers this morning about
gluten-free diets and about how they're
not as healthiest they're often cracked
up to be
right well I think there's two reasons
why people go after these plant-based
diets and you know myself included
there's one is there's there's an
environmental kind of imperative and
reason why plant centric diets would
kind of represent a more important part
of the future of our food supply as a
world you know ten billion people and
using animals as an intermediary to
produce our food is is not the most
resource efficient so that's a very
important fundamental
kind of food policy and a lot of people
are taking their own moral position on
that but when it comes to the actual
products and health consumption there's
two reasons that I mean people want a
transparency around their food so they
want to understand how it was processed
what's in it so minimal ingredients are
really important and then the second
thing is that both micro and macro
nutrients so our company really has a
lot of focus on both supplying
additional ingredients like calcium we
have a lot of products that have protein
in them so we have products that are
protein equivalent to milk and then many
times people just want a light low sugar
or no sugar alternative without a lot of
calories so they prefer the product
without as much protein what about the
competition though I mean a lot of the
big boys of the global drinks industry
have moved into areas like yours or dr.
pepper PepsiCo and so forth how hard
does that make life views of small
independent well I guess we're a small
and independent because we like that
little bit of that point of view and
allows you to be nimble quicker to
market closer to the consumer and I
think the way our company packages
things has kind of just an honest
authenticity that the consumer responds
really well to and because we don't have
big industrial manufacturing systems we
can be flexible with our packaging we
can have creative designs we have a
curvy ball that is very ergonomic for
folks so they're just little touches
that go into having a small you know
consumer friendly company that makes it
help drive the market forward a little
bit now the last drinks business that
you found it ended up being bought by
coca-cola right is
calathea going to go the same way
eventually I hope not I hope that I mean
look well older and wiser as they say
but
think we've got a capital structure and
shareholders which are much more
interested in a long-term perspective
back then I as an entrepreneur I kind of
lost control of the the company from a
capital basis and those investors had
smaller timeframes in mind here we
really think it's a long where at the
beginning of a very fundamental shift in
the food supply I think people
underestimate how radical the food
system is about to change and both from
the pressure on the really big companies
by these investment strategies and the
type of 3G Management which is really
stripping out the R&D and the creativity
on enforcing just a complete bottom line
regime on management which is very tough
to innovate after that so I think it's a
just you know sky's the limit for small
companies that really listen to the
consumer